i when i see a homeless person
i'm not always going to give them money
sometimes i give them a dollar some
change whatever you know i can't give to
everybody i'm not balling out like that
but what i will always do is i will look
them in the eye and wish them
the best and i'll just say like i can't
but you know i really hope you
i hope you get something today you know
because most people
they don't want to look at them because
it reminds them of this part of themself
that maybe
they're too afraid that they could and
they're one step
one bad decision away from getting there
themselves and it's scary to look at a
person
who is very sick and very poor
and very needy because especially when
you
are opulent in so many ways and i think
what
most people what those people need more
than anything else is a meal and a
conversation
and if i have the time dude and you're
not completely crazy which
i have i have i mean i've encountered
too man i mean one guy
i was just like talking about a story
and he's like well if the [ __ ] aliens
and the government
didn't [ __ ] come in and take my brain
and i was like
oh this is a whole other level
i can't help you oh god well that's most
people homeless or not in florida
yeah yeah and you're like you want some
of these mushrooms
i mean i saw when i got off i got i got
off a bus yesterday
um and i immediately saw a guy that was
clearly on
a you know a hardcore drug addict he's
like do you have any money i was like i
don't have any cash
but i have a fresh gatorade in my bag
and you can
totally have that like that's one and he
just looked at it
like oh yes a cold
beverage like on a hot day i never
expected that
dude one time a guy was like a guy
approached me an intersection in l.a
he was like do you have any money on you
and i was like no cause i didn't
but i had a bottle of hand lotion
of of cream and i was like dude and i
gave them in this
and this guy looked at it like it was a
[ __ ] hundred dollar bill was he ashy
he was very ashy oh yes
which another great rose joke about me
thank you fifi dash said uh
alex is the ashmashious man from
baltimore from a city that was burned by
crackheads or something like that
uh great [ __ ] joke really good but
yeah he was basically because if you're
homeless
that is the last thing you're going to
spend money on is oh yeah
you're thinking of so many other things
you're not thinking of your skin even
though it hurts
to be to be that dry and that was one of
those things where it's like
it's those little things giving someone
a pair of socks
is worth so much more than giving them a
dollar sometimes because it's the things
that they wouldn't buy
and you know again i can't do it for
everybody
but if i have the time and a little bit
of extra
i'm more than happy to give it away i
have this philosophy that and it's a lot
of people's like
it can it's a lot of people think like
this i didn't come up with this
but whatever you give out will come back
to you twofold
eventually so if i give a homeless
person a dollar
somewhere along the way i will be
rewarded with two dollars
i don't know how i don't know where i
don't know when but that but it's gonna
happen
right and if you think like that then
it's so much easier to give it you know
i don't need to hoard
a dollar right that means the world to
this person it means
nothing you know so
i just try to think like that as much as
i can that's why the roasting thing is
so fun for me is because if you
don't know who i am you don't realize
that
i'm this completely paradoxical person
to what i present myself as on stage
and that's just this flamboyant
character that i'm just having fun and
being silly with
but the real truth is i [ __ ] love
everyone i have so much compassion
for humanity and i'm so hopeful for
our existence and that's what i really
want to convey and i think that's what
comes off in my podcast and why people
are willing to talk to me about this
[ __ ]
that's [ __ ] amazing have you ever
heard of a soft white underbelly
no he's a guy his name is mark later
he's a uh he's a professional
photographer he used to be like work in
the advertising world and he used to
work for like big ad agencies he takes
like all like the product photos for
apple
that kind of [ __ ] and uh and then
basically
he quit doing that and then he opened up
he bought this little studio in on skid
row
and he just takes in homeless people and
he just sits there and interviews them
for 30 minutes
whoa and his channel he started it
i think he started like maybe last year
beginning of last year
and it's already got almost 2 million
subscribers and he is like blowing up
like he gets like these people on there
that just tell these stories and it's
for some reason it really connects to
people like these like he asks these
people
how they ended up where they are like a
lot of them homeless one guy had like a
gun
of shotgun wound through his face he had
half of his face missing jesus and like
the worst most [ __ ] up people on earth
and uh he said the word the number one
common denominator
with all those people is [ __ ] up
parents yeah
that's a it's a big one it's huge i mean
the thing is those are such
informative years on you that you know
from
from one until like nine yeah is
your parents are your biggest influences
in your life
and if they are abusive if they're
dismissive
if they're absent if they're if they're
too much of one thing
that is all getting directed toward you
in a way that you don't know how to cope
with yet
and that's so difficult and so these
people learn terrible habits and they
don't feel enough love early on
and that is a big thing i one of the
things i love doing when i'm on the road
is i walk i just walk around cities
right that's how i ended up in that
shitty area of miami because i'm just
like well i don't know where i'm going
i'll just walk
so i but i love if i'm not if i realize
that a homeless person is not at all
threatening like they go hey man can i
get a can i get a dollar or something
i'm like
why don't do you want to do you want
some food like oh you want there's a
hamburger place right here you want to
sit outside and just have a burger i'll
buy you a burger
and then i just talk to him because most
people
they're the biggest thing that they're
missing i mean other than pants
and you know clean clothes and things
like that it's it's communication yeah
they don't have a core of people to talk
to
she's like shane if you had a problem
you would have a couple people that
you're like i know exactly who i need to
call right now and i got to talk this
[ __ ] out and i got buddies or i got
family that i can be like okay i'm
calling you up and i need you for 20
minutes or whatever
these people don't have that [ __ ] right
and so sometimes i'll just be a voice
to them and what i find is when i'm on
the road and i talk to people
because i'm good at asking questions
that people know that
i'm a fleeting uh moment of their life
that i'm not sticking around
i don't live where you are so they tell
me a lot of things
that people normally wouldn't tell you
i've had
so i've been in florida for a week now
i've had two women tell me the story of
how they were widowed
in a week and i'm just i'm just drinking
i'm just having a beer with them after a
show
and they feel the thing is they feel
this comfort with me because they know
that i'm going to be gone right in a day
you're not judging them
no i'm just listening to them right and
so that things that would be very that
would take a long time for them to tell
someone that they wanted to be in a
relationship with and
of any kind they will put out on me
because i'm about to leave
so there's this trust in strangers yeah
that you kind of just like will tell
people things so that's why i think that
that's why that's so successful is
because these are human interest stories
that
people don't seek out otherwise
it's hard to listen to a homeless person
talk about when their kids were taken
away because they got too [ __ ] up on
drugs and then they lost their job and
then the house mortgage turned and
flipped on him and
the stories of how those people got
there are heartbreaking
and for a lot of people they can't stand
to listen to them
but so for someone who is taking the
time to look for them
and to interview them and to just spend
some time
really talking to them like a person
that's
the that's the most beautiful thing